it hey let's talk about Bitcoin cuz
you're smarter than I am and I was out
you know Ito did this group chat
yesterday type thing I can't remember
exactly what they called it but it was
really cool because I got to get on
there and there's a few people on there
who I liked I always searched Bitcoin
Twitter you know and just I don't they
don't follow them but I pay attention to
them and I got to you know kind of chat
with some of the people who I follow
Twitter so that was really cool and I
got to go out of good opinion so
obviously I'd like to hear your opinion
cuz everyone has one of why the price is
not rapidly rising at this point yeah I
mean look it's a liquidity crisis right
meaning that everyone wants dollars and
so every asset is gonna get sold off
whether it's stocks commodities Bitcoin
whatever it is and people want dollars
but as soon as that liquidity crisis
ends either because there's a flood of
dollars that into the market through
intervention from the government or
people realize wait a minute I don't
need as many dollars as I previously
thought I can now go buy other assets
you'll see those prices stabilize and
ultimately recover and so the the beauty
of all of this is if you understand how
money works you don't get shaken out
when the liquidity crisis happens right
if you can kind of weather the storm and
hold your assets but also you've got
cash kind of cash is king right and he
who has the cash makes the rules and the
liquidity crisis yeah yeah I but I
bought a couple more bitcoins at 5,000
when it dropped down there I thought I
thought that was a good idea I thought
that was really really nice price and I
never thought I could get some at that
price that being said you know what as I
search Bitcoin Twitter I feel maybe more
nervousness then I've ever felt from
that crowd and obviously when you when
you searched it you're gonna get all
kinds of responses all all aboard you
know you're gonna have 27 people saying
the price is going to $30,000 you have
27 people say prices go to 9000 tomorrow
you know it's like people are all over
the board but there is uh you know not
everybody but there's a certain amount
of people who are nervous because and I
believe you said this also but it's like
this is the perfect storm for Bitcoin so
either it's going
maker it's good error it's not you know
either it's gonna prove that it is this
safe has been an asset and it's better
than then the USD or it's not and we're
gonna probably find that out within the
next three to six months yeah so I I
kind of believe some of that but some of
it I disagree with and so the way I look
at it is it's definitely the perfect
storm right you've got a quantitative
easing you got the Bitcoin having all
this stuff with that said I don't think
it'll happen in three to six months I
think it's more of like 18 to 24 month
time frame and I don't necessarily think
that if Bitcoin materially increase in
u.s. dollar value in that time frame
that bitcoins done right like I don't
think that it'll go away I don't think
that it'll be you know I'm not secure
etcetera what I think is people will
have to go back and revisit what the
thesis for the asset is right because
that wouldn't serve kind of this idea
that the having an inflation hedge asset
etc proved to be true I'm still in the
camp where I believe that pretty
strongly voted with my dollars that way
and kind of converting them to Bitcoin
etc but you know we'll see what happens
over the next two years give or take
yeah the other thing that I find an
issue that people aren't really that
they don't ever bring up on Bitcoin
Twitter a lot of people bring up that
the u.s. is gonna print six trillion
dollars but no one brings up the fact
that bitcoin is a it's a worldwide asset
and the number that all of the central
banks across the world is gonna print is
way way way way more than six trillion
dollars I mean I don't want to say every
central bank is gonna start printing
money but a lot of them are and so the
numbers gonna be I don't know double
that triple that so there's gonna be all
this extra money floating around that
that could find its way into Bitcoin
yeah there's this guy Brent Johnson that
I recently brought on the podcast I run
something called Santiago capital and
he's got this theory that he calls the
dollar milkshake theory and it's this
whole idea of
everyone around the world the central
banks are making a milk shake what
they're doing is they're injecting
liquidity into the market they're
printing money right they're injecting
it into the market but only one country
gets to have the straw to drink the milk
shake and he says that's the United
States with the US dollar because
everyone wants dollars so everyone's
injecting liquidity in and the US is
sucking that liquidity out by bringing
it all into the dollar and so he the
reason why he believes that is he thinks
the dollar will get much stronger etc
but if you kind of take that example a
little bit further you get this idea of
you know look at the Australian dollar
the Australian dollars fall in like 30
40 50 percent in the last couple of
weeks against the US dollar so all of a
sudden if you're in Australia it's not
so much that you want to just get out of
the Australian dollar you either want to
get US dollars or get Bitcoin well a lot
of times bitcoins going to be more
accessible than getting US Dollars and
so I think that you're right in that
like a global basis there will be more
demand for the asset as you see those
currencies being devalued